L
HURT THEIR POLITICAL ENEMIES.
VERY MUCH INCLUDING YOU, SO KEEP
THAT IN MIND.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU ENDED DEMOCRACY
IN CANADA.
HE DECLARED MARTIAL LAW THIS
WEEK.
THE IRONY IS HE SEEMS TO BE
LOSING CONTROL OF CANADA, THANK
GOD, AND HE'S BECOME A MORE
DESPERATE BY THE DAY.
JUST TODAY, A CONSERVATIVE
MEMBER PARLIAMENT CHALLENGED
TRUDEAU AND IN RESPONSE, TRUDEAU
ACCUSED HER OF STANDING WITH.
>> CONSERVATIVE PARTY MEMBERS
CAN STAND WITH PEOPLE WHO WAVE
SWASTIKAS, WITH PEOPLE WHO WAVE
THE CONFEDERATE FLAG.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T KNOW THE
MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT HE WAS
TALKING TO.
WE BELIEVE SHE IS JEWISH,
THOUGH.
MEANWHILE, JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN CARRYING OUT
THEIR THREAT TO SEE IS THE BANK
ACCOUNTS AND CRYPTOCURRENCY LAWS
OF ANYONE WHO CRITICIZES
JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
BY THE WAY COME OUR STATE
DEPARTMENT HAS SAID NOTHING
ABOUT THIS.
AS DEMOCRACY ENDS AND TEAR ANY
RAINS, OUR CLOSEST ALLY IN THE
WORLD, JOE BIDEN
STATE DEPARTMENT HAS NOT SAID A
WORD.
BECAUSE HUNGRY IS DANGEROUS.
MAN, THEY ARE DISHONEST.
THE GOVERNMENT JUST BANNED 34
CRYPTO WALLETS LINKED TO THE
FREEDOM CONVOY.
THEY HAVE BEEN HARASSING ANYONE
WHO DARED TO DONATE TO THE
TRUCKERS.
TODAY "THE WASHINGTON POST"
OWNED BY THE WORLD'S RICHEST MAN
BEGAN CONTACTING PEOPLE WHO
DONATED AS LITTLE AS $40 TO THE
CONVOY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
THAT'S NOT JOURNALISM.
IT'S AN INCITEMENT TO VIOLENCE
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
THEN A REPORTER AT THE OTTAWA
CITIZEN EXPOSED THE IDENTITY OF
A CAFE OWNER WHO DARED TO DONATE
$250 TO THE CONVOY.
THAT HONOR IS RECEIVING THREATS
AND SHE HAD A CLOSE HER
BUSINESS.
THIS AFTERNOON, ILHAN OMAR
TWEETED THIS "I FAILED TO SEE
WHY ANY JOURNALIST FELT THE NEED
TO REPORT ON A SHOP OWNER MAKING
SUCH AN ANGST SIGNIFICANT
DONATION THEN TO GET THEM
HARASSED.
IT IS UNCONSCIONABLE AND
JOURNALISTS NEED TO DO BETTER."
ILHAN OMAR IS GENERALLY PRETTY
LOATHSOME, BUT WHEN SHE SAYS
SOMETHING THAT IS TRUE, WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE HER CREDIT FOR IT.
BECAUSE UNLIKE THE LAS VEGAS
SUN, WE ARE NOT LIARS.
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON IS A SENIOR
FELLOW AT THE HOOVER INSTITUTION
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" CHEERING
ON AND MAKE POSSIBLE THE
HARASSMENT OF SMALL DOLLAR
DONORS TO A TRUCK DRIVER CONVOY.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I THINK THEY ARE
INADVERTENTLY DOING THEIR BEST
TO MAKE A TENEMENT SQUARE SCENE
WHERE THEY ARE IN THE TANK AND
THE TRUCKERS ARE THE CITIZEN
THAT SAYS COME ON.
I DON'T THINK THEY INTENDED TO
MAKE THIS A FAULT LINE OR TO BE
ICONIC.
WHAT IS HAPPENED, TALKER, AS THE
TRUCKERS HAVE BEEN ICONIC OF
THOSE FAULT LINE THROUGHOUT THE
MIDDLE OF NORTH AMERICA.
AND ON ONE SIDE, YOU HAVE THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MUSCULAR AND THEY
BRAVED THE WEATHER AND THEY ARE
OUT THERE WITH CULVERT AND THEY
ARE BRINGING HER FOOD AND ARE
BUILDING MATERIALS AND OUR FUEL
AND THEY ARE OPPOSED BY THE SAME
CLASSES WHOSE PROFITED DUE TO
THESE TRUCKERS.
AND PEOPLE LIKE THEM.
AND YET THE TRUCKERS TEND TO
HAVE THE PRAGMATIC -- THEY ARE
IN THE REAL-WORLD PAIR THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH REAL THINGS.
AND THEY HAVE GREATER COMMON
SENSE, SADLY LOOK AT OMICRON AND
THEY SAY THIS NATURAL -- THIS
VIRUS IS IN ITS DESCENDANTS.
IT IS MORE INFECTIOUS, BUT IT'S
NOT AS LETHAL SO PEOPLE ARE
GETTING HERD IMMUNITY.
IT IS TIME TO LET UP.
AND AFTER ALL, WE ARE -- WE GIVE
ALL THESE PRACTICAL REASONS WHY
YOU SHOULD LISTEN TO THEM AND
THE GOVERNMENT HAS NO ANSWER AND
YET THAT THEY ARE A GOVERNMENT
OF KNOWLEDGE AND INTELLECT AND
THEY CAN'T ANSWER THEM FOR THE
TRUCKERS ARE ALSO SAYING, YOU
KNOW, THIS FAULT LINE IS MORE
ABOUT US -- IT'S ABOUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE OF THESE
SYMMETRICAL APPLICATION OF THE
LAW.
THERE WAS PROTEST ALL THROUGHOUT
AMERICA, CANADA TOO.
OVER 1,000 SAID THAT BLM DIDN'T
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK.
AND SO EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE TRUDEAU GOVERNMENT WAS
FOR THE BLM AND NT 4.0.
AND THEY HAD NO RATIONAL
SYSTEMATIC FAIRNESS THAT
TRUCKERS ARE BRINGING THAT UP.
AND ULTIMATELY, I DON'T THINK
TRUDEAU IS GOING TO WIN THIS.
HE HAS A PAJAMA BOY PRO SEWN UP.
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE, PRACTICAL PEOPLE.
EVENTUALLY, TRUDEAU IS GOING TO
LOSE.
AGAINST AN ENTRENCHED
BUREAUCRATIC ELITE AND THE
CORPORATION OF SILICON VALLEY
VERSUS THE AVERAGE PERSON HAS
NOTHING OTHER THAN COMMON SENSE
AND POPULAR SUPPORT.
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE